in this day and age as being an
a single person who happens to be
incredibly successful and regardless of
what you think that level of notoriety
that you have is or fame is it's there i
just think it's really hard in to to uh
kind of plot your way through that world
regardless it is moneyless and and
everything is hard but it's harder when
you you're a target is what i'm saying
well and it must be harder to find
someone if who's looking for a
partnership and you like your alone time
like you don't want to talk you said
you'd be surprised at how many
younger generation women feel exactly
the same way they say
until they get to yes they they change i
mean i feel like i am an expert to a
degree on women in their 20s and trust
me the difference between 21 25 and 30
is enormous those are very different
stages men mature and grow and evolve
much slower than women
women it all takes place in that one
decade when they're 20
it's they're in that experimental phase
usually you know that's college and
they're kind of wild and i mean you
really want to stay away from that i
mean that would be too young even for me
even for you oh yes unless they're
incredibly mature
[Laughter]
but by the time they're 25 i think
most women are very different they're
over that
you know wild phase um
and
by the time they're 30 they may have a
biological clock ticking and then it may
be scary
or not i mean it's not like it was when
even when i was first talking about this
subject in the 90s on politically
incorrect i remember i was sort of a a
tribune for the single person because
even in the 90s it was still sort of
considered weird
if you weren't somehow angling to be
a parent somehow if you didn't want
children or if you wanted to stay single
i remember doing once a a you don't
think it's weird now you don't think
you're uh no now it's not weird it's not
my brother
alex actually just brought up the other
day how the birth rate is lower than the
death rate now correct so there's a lot
more people that are not having right
yeah so there's a lot more people
nowadays that are not happy look what
you started there's no st right there's
no stigma i remember once we did a
sketch
uh it was a valentine to myself it was
valentine's day and it was a tribute to
people who just wanted you know like i
was making the statement that
valentine's day doesn't have to just be
about pledging undying love to another
person why can't it just be me saying
i love me and i want to be with me and i
doesn't mean i don't have love in my
life it just doesn't mean i i followed
this model i mean the
the concept of modern marriage is very
new but even if you have a girlfriend
i'm sure she loved that that you did a
valentine's day tribute to yourself
well uh she might do one to herself
i mean that's very antiquated thinking
that a good girl that i'm sorry that a
girl wouldn't like that um
just because it's so old-fashioned
jackie i'm sorry i am right you might be
and that's fine she is no i'm not
well the point is that you that
everything is on the buffet right now
you can be that kind of person i mean
like i was talking to we had a guest on
the show uh friday night who wrote a
book called uh rethinking sex and we
were talking about it on the show and
then after
and
i think this was after i was mentioning
that
you know what oh i think it was also on
with that
what
she is discovering in the millennial
generation
are things that
my generation takes for granted like
like that um
women can't really separate sex from
feeling i'm like yeah duh
we were we knew this forever that's not
new
it's new to them because that generation
is so [ __ ] up with their dating apps
and their phones and their [ __ ] pride
and they thought they could like be
somehow
above all this and not really care and
date by tinder and of course they can't
because it's in the dna of women that of
course if you are going to have sex with
somebody you're going to as they would
say catch feelings like it's a disease
but that
isn't that scary for you who who at you
know goes into it not having any
feelings but to know that you might i do
have what are you saying i don't have a
feeling well you don't have it you don't
want to just be i mean you're conflating
things that don't deserve to be
conflated tell me what i'm doing wrong
okay
well you're married no uh
i mean you're i wasn't i wouldn't have a
co-host i just did it for the co-host
uh don't forget what i'm conflating you
said i said yeah because of
a person well you're saying you're
you're you're you're making it out to be
that unless you have undying love for
one person your whole life there can be
no love there's only either i'm not
saying that here's what i'm saying well
it sounds like you're saying that but
here's what i'm saying it's not one or
the other one well here's what i'm
saying as a single person regardless at
different times in your life maybe not
right now you might be in a relationship
and we won't talk about that but we will
talk about the fact that
one of the things you said the
attributes of being alone is or or being
single is if you want to go have sex you
can go have sex it's never that just
that same old same old all the time you
can what if you just wanted to have fun
and have sex and not be concerned about
the other person
might catch feelings and you're not
interested in that i have caught
feelings i have feelings right now
i love you too
no that's not what i meant
i mean that's true too but i absolutely
have feelings
it's just you know
it's just you don't you don't always
have to go all the way to baghdad
is baghdad marriage no baghdad is an
analogy i'm making toward uh about when
um
we invaded iraq the first the first time
right right and
after we kicked saddam hussein out of
kuwait right right uh a lot of people
said we should go all the way to baghdad
and kill hussain saddam hussein and take
over the country right which is what his
stupid son did
and look at how [ __ ] up that was and
george bush the first who was very wise
in this he said look we just went in
there right to kick him out of kuwait
right we're not gonna go all the way to
baghdad you don't always have to go all
the way to baghdad you see what i'm
saying you can you can love somebody and
not go all the way to baghdad
the marriage i said marriages
he went all the way to baghdad right and
my wife and i are both still in shock
and on
[Music]
you